Two boar attacks, two very different outcomes.
Here's how a scene in "House of the Dragon"
had fans thinking back to the first season
of "Game of Thrones."
Much of the third episode of "House of the
Dragon" revolves around a rather pathetic
royal stag hunt in the Kingswood, and King
Viserys' troubles regarding matters of family
and succession.
Princess Rhaenyra Targaryen is technically
traveling with the king, but wants absolutely
nothing to do with the staged hunt, let alone
the clumsy and self-serving social activities around it.
Making it even less appealing is Lord Jason
Lannister of Casterly Rock, who is aspiring
to win her hand in marriage.
"Thank you for the wine."
Rhaenyra chooses to distance herself from
the proceedings by taking a ride in the woods,
accompanied by her hand-picked Kingsguard
member Ser Criston Cole.
Their stay in the forest ends up going on
quite a bit longer than anyone but Rhaenyra
is comfortable with, and even includes a brief
encounter with a majestic stag that's markedly
different from Viserys' experience.
But it's another notable incident during Rhaenyra
and Ser Criston's forest jaunt brings an entirely
different, and much later, king to mind.
As Princess Rhaenyra and Ser Criston are hanging
out in the forest, a mysterious noise from
the bushes prompts them to investigate.
The source of the sound turns out to be an
extremely disgruntled wild boar, which charges
Criston and sends the knight flying.
The boar then attempts to attack and gore
Rhaenyra, but fortunately, the pair manages
to kill the animal in the nick of time.
"Game of Thrones" fans will immediately remember
another time a boar attacked a royal in the woods.
King Robert Baratheon is grievously wounded
when a boar attacks him during a hunting expedition
that also takes place in the Kingswood.
This is an incredibly important event, since
Robert's death leads into the arrest and execution
of Ned Stark, and sets the stage for the bloody
succession conflict that fuels the rest of the series.
While there are obvious similarities between
the boar attacks in "House of the Dragon"
and "Game of Thrones," there are also very
clear differences.
The boar attack in "Game of Thrones" is a
highly shady affair, as the Lannisters have
made sure that Robert had plenty to drink
the night before the hunt.
The attack itself also happens offscreen between
episodes, as if to underscore the highly underwhelming
nature of King Robert's rule.
"My fault.
Too much wine.
Missed my thrust."
The boar scene in "House of the Dragon" happens
fully on screen, and the end result of the
terrifying encounter couldn't be more different,
either.
While Robert dies a sad, contemplative death
in bed while making a hasty attempt to set
his affairs in order and right past wrongs,
Rhaenyra rides back to the hunting party with
the dead boar in tow, looking more regal than
ever and drawing awed and admiring looks from
everyone who sees her.
The effect of Rhaenyra bagging a dangerous
boar with just one knight is further enhanced
by the fact that many of the people present
just saw her father's bungling attempts to
put a stag out of its misery, despite the
fact that people were literally holding it
for him to stab.
So when Robert meets a boar, his rule — and
his life — come to a pitiful end.
Rhaenyra encounters one and not only lives
to tell the tale, but gains bucketloads of
respect that'll surely prove worth its weight
in gold going forward.